ancora ma dopo anni ancora esiste super
hot ma veramente dai ragazzi hanno fatto
una nuova versione di super hot dopo 800
anni cioè da quando aperto il canale
cariche che vedesi stesso gioco è uno
dei pochi giochi che compro e son
contento di spenderesti 15 euro quanto
costa perché è fatto bene è quindi
ragazzi oggi siamo su super hot mind di
cose va bene bios operating system of
the feature va bene tutorial punto exe
madonna come nomi che ogni volta si può
fare un menù normale porca vacca inizia
gioco perfetto un attimo sono aprea
partito bilanciere ammira veramente da
cani frate beh allora prima è andato
ragazzi super hot per chi non lo
conoscesse dalla falsa premessa è un
gioco dove se ti muovi gli altri si
muovono normali se stai fermo tutto si
frisa e quindi tu puoi sparargli in
faccia tranquillamente come i proiettili
sono limitati poi anche per la beta 6
matrix presse at work switching twain e
miss sacrificata nuova veramente st
romano la salute aiuto non mi ricordavo
neanche ce stai galli mi chiama e
frenetico un attimo mica gli altri super
hot erano molto più easy becca testa
tazzina grazie
mi ha colpito no xvi scintu di enemies
bakwa ma serve fighissima scusate
abbiamo allora non posso mai perdere
basta che switch out vicino attore di
quindi posso cominciare solo una volta
ogni tanto va bene
intanto quello che sposa la testa a caso
la mamma degli haters va bene puoi anche
lanciare le armi e volevo farvelo vedere
però non si è fatto niente quindi vorrei
posso tieniti regalo e comunque ragazzi
sto gioco è veramente un casino anche se
sembra facile perché sto riuscendo nota
sappiate che non è così semplice possono
fare lo switch sì quindi ma se c'è lo
switch è molto più facile raga lo switch
che aggiusta di brutto la vita cioè
incredibile siamo a 12 per cento
posso mettermi fuori posso scegliere
oggi aumenti la vita di un hp oppure
telara ricarichi dai mettiamola di un hp
così a me non devo fare bene come
minchia sono un mattone tiene dal regalo
mamma mia che mi era brutta threesixty
no
una scarpa cos'è questo
mazza distruggendo tutti i vasi gli
egizi ai a meno ma lercio tukory aia di
randello aia
mi chiamo hanno scioccato malissimo è
come disconnette cosa da zero devo farli
tutti senza mai morire ma voi siete
trovati
ecco perché mi sembrava troppo facile no
non è vero ma veramente devo farli tutti
senza mai morire
lo show è che sporca la cake il
bellissimo è stato bellissimo mi
sembrava troppo facile infatti dicevo ma
è abbastanza semplice per essere super 8
invece no è perché devi farli di fila
che se muore una volta rienzi da zero
alla fascia ragazzi gay e va bene quanta
gente e auto fermo
grazie lucido perfetto susa body no non
ce la faccio anche senza perfetto per
chi è tipo è diventato michael jackson
quando gli ho sparato ma inglese max o
che non moriamo perché prima ho fatto un
colpirla perché pensavo fosse semplice
fece non lo è per niente mi servirebbe
la la pista che è il culo che ho avuto
123 no questo non so che colpiranno
perfetto 34
mamma mia che mira brutta questo non era
manco morto come schiacciate maledetti
perfetto da tour milk è uscito questo
meno male che mi ha mancato fortissimo
perfetta siamo a tre ragazzi siamo a tre
ce la posso fare
mi dai un bonus ogni volta se va 21 per
cento ma se non ce la farò mai sul
computer
la tastiera minchia se mi vedevi giocare
a getting over it quante tastiere o
lanciato dove il titolo platon un
televisore in testa che male ma perchè
non morite se vi si spara in bocca
ok perfetto va grande hanno definito chi
che manca or cavalca le visto questi
c'è un mitra a lo lanci non puoi sparare
effettivamente un trapano noi che poi fa
chissà che cosa c'è ancora tanta gente
che perfetto in the pen e ci sto
riuscendo fermi tutti zitti anche perché
non è non è normale in crisi vita vai o
che questo avevo fatto prima a tele mixa
quindi non sono in ordine ogni volta
perfetta ancora peggio dichiara che non
devo morire assolutamente mai so
veramente una mira che fa pietà
ok perfetto no si è rotta pistola
aiutato noah ragano mi va di iniziare da
zero ma che mira ma [ __ ]
non ci credo la gara difficilissimo a
cagare
ma qui ogni volta che cambio corpo
lancia la pistola ma perché ma chiedilo
a yacht a enna minchia meno male che
avevo un cuore in più raga draga
difficilissimo ve lo giuro
l'ho preso ok perfetto perfetto ho
bisogno una domanda le vite che perdo
sono cumulabili nel senso adesso riparto
con tre vite o sono sempre una
vabbè è meglio non scoprirlo dai
figuriamoci se anche solo ci speravo di
prenderlo che devo lanciare gli a lovely
aeroplanini sto livello che a quanto
difficile porca vacca
beh beh no effetto non è vero ma
preferisco sempre i proiettili
volevi 1 ok perfetto che sia stato
semplice su regale mancano tv 3 quindi
sono messo anche bene al 7 su 10 siamo
mini mancano 3
vai aiuto fuori madonna che male da un
regalo quando di arrivare in faccia mi
fa troppo ridere madonna perfetto
perfetto da
ok disputare grado giugno non è morto
quando ci mettete perfetto mai così i
ragazzi cos'è sta roba una bistecca
porca vacca che male che fa questo se
colpisce minchia che dolore forte però
non li ammazza forse assisi li ammazza
propria volata alla gamba la prendo io
mio falegname con 10 euro la faceva
meglio
ok feto regalo
mamma mia che male o finiti dischi raga
questo lanciamo le frecce
cos'è mara freccetta schiazza maledetto
super hot era lagane mancano 2 9 su 10
dove che siamo aiuto
vieni
perfetto mi chiamano vale per imparato
in fretta come giocare a sta roba
suonare un casino
ok benissimo stanando dativo in questa
bravo no che ho finito le munizioni
perfetto dopo cristiano malgioglio e
quando perde l'arma a casina certo raga
ok nove su dieci l'abbiamo fatta ma
anche al 10 su 10 abbiamo finito
se dio vuole abbiamo così decriptato
tutto ma dai alla fine va bene 10 su 10
macchina da scrivere o se perdi in
questa mi incazzo che ho fatto tutto
maledizione ero indeciso se
teletrasporta misto di lui o se rubargli
l'arma ed evacuato e siamo a due
la partenza è buona
ok
c'è il fucile posso prendermela finito
il regalo ok perfetto no
la madonna mi chiamo chuck norris
perfetto raga di gesù non è stato facile
processo riuscito
il che è un miracolo bene cosa mi fa
vedere adesso siamo a 10 segreto degli
illuminati da spiegare
lui
roma domani non è quello di prima
quindi a perché prima la modalità facile
se medium siete interrogati male spero
che non ce la farò mai a fare 10 medio
vabbè ma mica ma siete scena vabbè ma è
impossibile
va bene basta va bene così
sono contento di essere morto non è vero
ragazzi spero che video vi sia piaciuto
come si deve anche per i soci ha condito
dalla descrizione sono esistite e
ricordatevi che siete su chi mi è venuta
bene non sono meno tra cani prove da
ragazzi